today on the Matt Walsh show the Supreme
Court will once again decide whether
religious employers should be allowed to
decline contraception coverage for their
employees or if they should be forced to
provide contraception to their employees
the left is screeching of course that
there's a plot afoot to steal women's
birth control but and they're always
talking about this but the interesting
thing is I've never heard anyone suggest
that we should ban birth control or get
rid of it or steal it or take it away
that's not actually what's that issue
here we'll talk about what is at issue
also a video of a man being shot in
Georgia has provoked very strong
reactions as you might expect so we'll
try to sort through the situation and
get to the truth or the closest
approximation of it that we can and
finally I will pass along some helpful I
hope and practical gift ideas for
Mother's Day so if you're
procrastinating and don't know what
you're gonna get your mother yet for
your wife really your wife you don't
know what you're getting your wife yet
for Mother's Day then stick around to
the end of the show because I got some
good suggestions okay so starting with
this yesterday the Supreme Court began
to hear arguments relating to birth
control coverage and if you've hear if
you feel like you've heard this song and
seen this dance before you have ever
since the Obama administration attempted
to force employers to provide free
contraception to their employees the
whole issue has been embroiled in legal
disputes and the Supreme Court has heard
several cases about it over the years
this time around the issue is about an
exemption passed by the Trump
administration allowing any company or
most companies any way to decline to
cover birth control if they have a
religious objection to birth control
Obama wanted to only give exemptions to
specifically religious organizations and
then he defined religious organization
in a pretty narrow way but that was
supposedly the idea right but the
trouble ministrations point is that hey
people who who run non religious
organizations also have religious
liberty you shouldn't have to be in a
religious organization or running one in
order to have your religious liberty
respected but the left says no
all employers should have to provide
contraception coverage does it matter
regardless of how they feel about it
regardless of their religious
convictions doesn't matter because women
have a right to birth control they have
a right to have their birth control
covered and now the Supreme Court is
weighing in again now as always with
this topic the left has been doing a lot
of posturing engaging in a lot of
hysterics and straw Manning and
everything else they you know we're
living in a Handmaid's Tale type of
stuff right there's been a lot of this
kind of thing from Camilla Harris who
tweeted once again this administration
has tried to control women's bodies it's
simple denying birth control coverage
will cost women more and this from
Bradley Whitford five conservative male
Supreme Court justices are about to
decide whether or not all you women out
there should have access to birth
control and lots of this kind of thing
for my Jana Presley absurd that in 2020
during a global public health crisis we
are still fighting before SCOTUS to
prevent employers from denying access to
contraception contraception is critical
to our health economic security and
bodily autonomy period hashtag hands off
my birth control and a lot of this kind
of thing from Amani Gandhi who's a
senior legal analyst apparently and she
says in all caps very simply they are
coming for your birth control okay
so let's break this down a little bit
first of all to this lame repetitive
boring crap about how men are trying to
take away birth control and men on
supreme court are deciding this and men
are plotting to control women's bodies
and everything else enough already
get a new routine okay you're boring me
feminists you're boring me to death
maybe that's maybe that's your goal to
bore all the men to death guess what roe
v wade was decided by men that was a
bunch of men deciding Roe so unless
you're gonna call for over the
overturning of roe v wade on the basis
that men decided it and they have no
business making these decisions about a
woman's body unless you're going to say
that I
want to hear any whining about men
getting involved in alleged women's
issues because it turns out that you're
perfectly fine with men being involved
as long as they agree with you what a
coincidence
it just so happens that yeah most men
shouldn't get involved in women's issues
but you do make a few exemptions
speaking of exemptions and it just so
happens that all the ones you exempt are
the ones who agree with you what a
coincidence
also by the way if a man is selfish and
he sees women as objects to be used do
you think he is likely to be for or
against birth control
think about this feminists use your
brains if you still have them is a
selfish cowardly controlling
objectifying man likely to be opposed to
birth control or in favor of it yes I am
mansplaining
to you right now and yes I'm doing in a
condescending tone because if you're
going with this line of reasoning you
deserve to be condescended to okay if
you don't understand this no you see the
kind of man that you're talking about he
wants to use you for sex so he loves
birth control
he loves abortion these are your allies
feminists the ally men who are who are
out there say yeah give them all the
birth control abortions they want do you
know why they're saying that because
they want to have sex without
consequence these are things that you
have to do in order to free him of
responsibility and he loves that so why
in god's name would you think that
there's some kind of patriarchal
conspiracy to rid the world of birth
control know if anything there's gonna
be a patriarchal conspiracy to put more
birth control into the world if anything
the birth control itself is a
patriarchal conspiracy if there's any
patriarchal and sick conspiracies
involved in the birth control issue it's
going to be on the Pro birth control
side I assure you
okay second point nobody
is coming for your birth control
nobody's trying to take your birth
control away nobody's trying to ban it
nobody is trying to reach into your
medicine cabinet at home and take it
from you nobody is trying to put you in
jail for using it nobody that doesn't
exist that's not a position that anybody
holds the question is whether simply an
employer should be required to provide
birth control to you and there's a
difference between saying so-and-so
shouldn't have to provide such-and-such
and saying so-and-so should be allowed
to prevent you from obtaining
such-and-such
you do see the difference though you
feminists it's pretty obvious do I need
to mansplain it more it's a pretty clear
difference but I know people on the Left
struggle with this difference a lot
anyway they they they really struggle
you guys really struggle to see the
difference between I don't want to have
to provide this to you and I think that
you should not have this thing like
completely different concepts there are
I can't even list them all there are
literally millions of things that exist
that I believe I shouldn't have to
provide to you or pay for or give to you
yet I think you should still have the
right to have those things
I just don't wanna be able to pay for it
that's all that's it
I'm third point in fact we'll get to the
third point in just a second before we
do you know if you're having car trouble
as we have been having a lot of car
trouble recently then and right now you
know to have car trouble can be pretty
difficult because your options are
limited in where you can go to get the
problem solved that's why Rock Auto
dot-com is a godsend rockauto.com is so
much easier than going to a store
especially these days and all the
questions you have to answer and then
what happens they ask you all these
questions they interrogate you
emasculate you maybe it's just me and
then they end up just having to order
right online anyway so cut out the
middleman go to rockauto.com it's unique
it's easy to navigate rockauto.com is a
family business serving Auto Park
customers online for 20 years
Rocca Rock auto comm always offers the
lowest prices available and they've got
the best selection so you really you
just can't beat it great selection easy
to navigate best prices you're gonna
find anywhere this is where you need to
go go to Rock Auto calm right now see
all the parts available for your car
truck and do me a favor write Walsh in
there how did you hear about us box so
that they know that I sent you
third point here about the birth control
thing
I am getting really tired of hearing
about this lack of access thing the
claim that women lack access to
contraception you can access
contraception anywhere it practically
rains from the sky in this country it
all but rains from the sky do you need
it to actually rain from the sky in
order to admit that you have access to
it all right I'm starting to think that
you know with feminists even even if
birth control was literally rating from
the sky like you could wake up in the
morning and there's birth control strewn
across your lawn like morning dew drops
you would still say that you had you
don't have access to it because you have
to physically walk out and bend down and
pick it up for yourself until there is
someone who will pick it up for you and
ferry it into your house and place it in
your mouth for you you're gonna say I
don't have access if you really are
having trouble accessing contraception
in this country don't take this the
wrong way then you're too incompetent to
be having sex anyway maybe this is a
good litmus test if you can't figure out
how to use country had to get your hands
on contraception then you are in
incompetent and you should be having sex
because any competent adult knows that
if you want birth control if you want
contraception you can find it in some
form at Target at Walmart and any
pharmacy at any gas station you can get
it for free at Planned Parenthood and if
it's that important you to you to have
it covered by your employer you can
always go to any of the countless
employers that cover it there is no
problem of access none you can get it
for free you can get it for cheap you
can get it over there you can get it
over there you get it anywhere you can
get it on a train and a plane in a house
with a mouse like a dr. Seuss book all
the sudden well no don't get birth
control from the mouse but you know
anywhere else you can pretty much get it
there is no problem of access none at
all
any competent adult if they want
contraception they can obtain it easily
and cheaply
once again if you're struggling with
this if you can't figure out how to get
your hands on birth control then don't
have sex and I'm not saying that
everybody should use birth control what
I'm saying though is that it's just a
thing that anyone should figure out how
to get their hands on if they really
want it fourth point feminists like to
say that their sex lives are none of our
business they like to say that their
bodies are none of our business
they'd like to say that their medical
decisions are none of our business I
agree wholeheartedly on every count it
is none of my business so stop talking
about it shut up about it if it's not my
business it's a very odd thing to tell
someone that something is none of their
business and then to all hours of the
day to it and then and then next all
hours of the day you're screaming about
it in their face
usually if something is none of other
people's business you keep it to
yourself what kind of adult goes around
whining about their birth control anyway
how embarrassing
that's your affair it's your business
your problem it's not my problem I'm
sorry it's not your employer's problem
either what is this thing I want to have
sex but I can't get birth control who
who goes around saying that but okay
figure it out what do you what do you
want us to facilitate your sex life are
you serious it's humiliating I'm
embarrassed for you
if you don't want it to be an issue up
for discussion stop making it an issue
up for discussion figure out your own
sex life and leave everybody else out of
it including your employer he doesn't
want to pay for it besides if it's if
it's none of anybody's business what are
you going to your employer who often
times as a man and saying give me birth
control I demand birth control
yeah real strong an independent woman
who does that goes crawling and whining
and crying - a male employer demanding
birth control v the Trump administration
is right religious liberty is not solely
the province of religious organizations
I don't have to be in a religious job or
have a religious vocation to have
religious liberty any more than I need
to be in the NRA to have gun rights now
you may not agree with people who are
opposed of birth control that's fine but
many religions not just Christianity
many religions have problems with
contraception because they see it as
something that contravenes God's plan I
mean that's that's the basic reason why
so many religions are against it you may
not agree doesn't matter you don't have
to agree it you're allowed to not agree
this is America but because it's America
if I run a business I can run my
business according to my religious
convictions don't like it get another
job if you don't want to work for a
devout religious person don't apply for
a job with a devout religious person
take some responsibility for your
actions
now just because of
subjection to birth control it doesn't
give them the right to come and pry it
out of your hands they can't break into
your home in the middle of the night and
steal all your birth control but it does
give them the right to decide that they
don't want to fund it provide it
facilitate it or be involved with it in
any way in any way in any way shape or
form and if you really value your
autonomy and privacy and dignity you
wouldn't want them to be involved in any
way shape or form all right I trust that
everything I've said here will now
settle the matter rather than just
inflaming feminist even more and making
them more pissed off let's go - actually
I was gonna say we're gonna go to five
headlines but we're not going to do five
headlines today instead I have just one
headline that I want to talk about at a
greater length that I normally do for
these news stories so I'm shelving five
headlines just for today to talk about
this this being the case of a mod R
burry this is a case that has sparked
mass protests and outrage and lots of
discussion much of the discussion has
consisted of reflexive and emotional
reactions that don't help us get to the
truth of the case and that's usually how
these things go now I in fact in one of
the people who offered one of those
unhelpful emotional reactions
unfortunately last night on Twitter a
Twitter always a great forum for talking
about these kinds of things what gets
all that in a moment
first the basics of the case as far as
we know if you're not familiar with it
there is now video that has been
released I'm not gonna play the video
because I mean it's not the kind of
video everybody wants to see but you can
easily go find it online if you want to
see it it shows a man running down the
road in the road and the video is being
taken from behind by a guy in another
car and then you see the running man
that's our Barry come up to two guys who
are stopped in the road they got there
in a pickup truck stopped in the road
and the you see are buried go around the
car like he's the
initially trying to get away and then
the camera doesn't capture the first
moment of the altercation but at some
point we see that our burry approaches
the man one of the men with the guns now
they're struggling there's a struggle
that ensues between our burry and one of
the men and and then the second guy
who's in the pickup truck standing on it
shoots three times I think it was and
kills our burry and he collapses and
dies that's what the video shows this
happened in February the men who did the
shooting have not been arrested haven't
been charged now there's gonna be a
grand jury seemingly in response to the
outrage or the claim being made by
supporters of our burry is that you know
he should have been arrested there this
should have happened back in February
the only reason they're doing it now is
because we noticed I think there may be
some truth to that this all happened in
Georgia by the way the men with guns are
Gregory and Travis McMichael they're
white barbers black the context appears
to be that there had been some break-ins
recently in the neighborhood and from
the way that it's being reported Gregory
and Travis McMichael thought that our
brie looked like the potential burglar
who had committed other burglaries there
is a parent there was apparently a
series of 911 calls that were placed
about our brie and his presence in the
neighborhood but apparently none of them
identified any clear crime that Aubrey
was committing so a couple of people
called but there wasn't clear what they
actually were concerned about that Arbor
was doing one was one mentioned that he
had been seen on a construction site and
maybe inside a half-built home it's not
clear that the McMichaels saw any crime
being committed exactly if they saw a
crime being committed or if they just
thought he looked like someone who had
committed a crime in the neighborhood at
some point they say the McMichael say
that they went to chase after our brie
and make a citizen's arrest and they say
they pursued him for a while and he was
trying to get away and then they cut him
off on the road
got out with guns he went after them
attacked they killed him so that's sort
of their version event the odd thing is
that the video shows the few seconds
leading up to this altercation and it
doesn't look like our burry is fleeing
the scene of a crime he appears to be
just jogging down the road now you'd
think if he was running away from a
crime you'd probably be trying to evade
detection he would be running in the
middle of street in the middle of the
day but that but that's what he's doing
the narrative from supporters of our
burry is that he was just out for a jog
and he hadn't committed any crime at all
and that is being reported by some media
outlets as fact I don't I don't I don't
think it is established fact but that's
that's one version of events that are
burry was out for a job I don't know a
jaw jog rather I don't know if that's
true or not the video does seem to lend
credence to that version of events but I
don't know he also seems to me to be
wearing what you would expect a person
to wear if they were out for a jog and
not what would you would expect them to
wear if they were on a burglary spree
it's also the time of day where you
would expect a jog and not a burglary
spree but again who knows I don't know
if our burry really committed a burglary
or not it's important to note though
that our brie is not accused of
committing any violent crime so far as
we know at this point say I've also seen
some people on social media who are more
inclined to defend the McMichaels who
are saying that are buried robbed he had
committed a robbery well there's a
difference between a robbery and a
burglary and the difference is important
he's not being accused of having FFF
being involved in any robberies being in
views accused of being involved in a
burglary which is a property crime it's
it's not like he held a gun to somebody
and took their wallet I think that
distinction is important and as far as
we know right now there is no claim that
he had on that day been witnessed by the
McMichaels committing a crime against
them
[Music]
or you know we don't know if they if
they witnessed any crime at all or if
they just had reason to believe that he
had we don't know it's also important to
note on the other side of this that the
police say there's a video of our burry
committing a burglary right before all
this ensued that's what we're being told
we haven't seen that video is it the
video of him on a construction site is
that what they're calling a burglary I
don't know we haven't seen it so let me
try to let me try to offer some thoughts
on this okay that's the that's like
those like the basics of the case so far
as I understand this so far first of all
as I already said the video is obsessing
because a man dies and you watch it
happen my initial reaction was an
emotional one based on having witnessed
that and and I said on Twitter always
says I said always a great forum for
these discussions that this is a
clear-cut case of first-degree murder
and the two shooters should get the
death penalty that was my first reaction
which is stupid obvious it's angry and
emotional it's a stupid thing to say on
my part I usually pride myself on being
the rational and logical one and not
jump into conclusions without evidence
and that's generally how I approach
these things I broke my own rule in this
case so I had to go back a couple hours
later and amend myself a bit because we
certainly can't call this clear-cut and
the idea that I could just declare not
only that it's murder but what degree of
murder it is it's just dumb so there's a
lot that isn't known there's a lot of
weirdness with this the video is along
with tragic very weird for a number of
reasons in that it doesn't appear to
fully fit either side's version of
events as far as I can tell though I do
think at this point it fits the site of
Arbor II supporters more more it seems
to me so based on what we know right now
it seems like the two sort of opposite
possibilities are this one Arbor II was
out for a jog the McMichaels thought he
fit the description of a burglar which
of course has very strong undertones of
he's a black guy running in a white
neighborhood right has undertones of
that well we don't know if that's what
it was but those are the undertones that
you know it's you can't get around and
and there's no there's no point tonight
and so they went after him he was out
for a jog they thought he looked like he
might be a criminal they went after him
he was innocent he defended himself
because he's got guys rolling up on him
with guns what else is he gonna do are
you gonna go I mean if two guys roll up
in a pickup truck with guns are you
gonna just do whatever they say maybe
you will but I think other other people
will be more inclined to fight for your
life because you don't know what these
guys intent and then he was killed so
that's that's one possibility one
version of events the other possibility
is this Arbor II was in the neighborhood
committing crimes so far there is no
suggestion that he had that day
committed any violent crimes or crimes
against persons he was committing in by
this version of events he was committing
a burglary or burglaries the McMichaels
witnessed him doing it or had strong
reason to believe that he had just done
it maybe we don't know what those
reasons are yet they go after him to
make a citizen's arrest he tries to get
away they keep pursuing they cut him off
on the road they grabbed their guns he
goes after them they kill him those seem
to be the two possibilities right now
maybe there's some kind of in-between
option between those two or or maybe the
truth is something very different from
any of this but I think for the truth to
be something very different from either
of the two options I laid out that would
require there to be a very significant
detail that right now we don't know
about and maybe there is right I can't
say if that detail exists or not
so I'm basing this on what we know and
remember this happened in February it's
not like it just happened that people
are making rushed judgments my point is
there's pretty good reason to believe
that we know basically most of the story
and that there aren't any more shoes to
drop but maybe there are
so here's my thing in option one they
went after an innocent man they
approached him with guns and you don't
pull a gun on someone unless you're
unless you're willing to use it and now
that innocent man is dead and they have
to pay for that so that to me is if
that's the case then it is pretty
clear-cut now in terms of assessing the
degree of murder and everything let's
I'm not gonna get into that again but
but but it's it's clear that there's a
very serious crime has been committed by
the shooters they need to go to jail and
answer for that you can't just kill a
guy while he's jogging because you think
he looks like he might have committed a
crime right
you can't go fully armed and loaded and
chase a guy down who fits a description
a guy who you think might have maybe
committed a crime at some point in the
past and then try to apprehend him and
kill him in the process that is
vigilantism at best and it's criminal
so if option one is true then the
shooters are fully in the wrong that
killed an innocent man and now it's just
a matter of assessing the degrees and
figuring out what their sentence is
going to be what about option two well
as it stands right now it's hard for me
to see how they wouldn't be in the wrong
the shooters I mean even if option two
is correct let's say best-case for them
based on what we know best case for them
right now is they witnessed a burglary
once again a burglary not a robbery
let's say they witnessed a burglary
does that give them the right to grab
their guns chase him down park in the
street and wait to ambush him even if
the ambush wasn't supposed to be deadly
is that the right response and if you do
that as a civilian and someone dies in
the process are you not responsible for
that I believe in giving people a ton of
leeway when protecting their own
property on their own property so if you
come on to a man's property and he's
there even if you didn't intend him harm
he has every right to assume that you
intend him harm and to and to react
accordingly so it is very rare that I
hear of a case in fact I can't think of
any case of the top of my head where
someone killed someone on their own
property and I think that person who
shot the gun should go to jail I can't
think of any case I mean maybe there's
been cases like that you know there
could be egregious other details but but
I think a lot of leeway when it comes to
protecting your own property your own
life your own family right so I believe
that I would also say that if they
witnessed this man attack someone abuse
someone someone said to me on Twitter
yesterday well what if they had seen him
you know raping a woman or something
like that would they be right to chase
after him then I would say yes chasing
him down could be a form of defending
the victim because this is a clearly a
physically dangerous man who's now on
the run he was just victimizing someone
and so chasing him down I think it was a
valiant and courageous thing to do and
you are you know in a sense defending
the victim even if it is after the fact
because you don't know if this guy could
come back or anything like that and yeah
you could call the cops but you could
still get away you know you can't count
on the cops to be there on time and so
you chase after him but none of that it
seems to apply to this situation he's
not he's not being accused of committing
any violent crime against anybody I
haven't heard that even the McMichaels
aren't making that claim no one's making
that claim at best from what we know
they might have seen a property crime a
burglary and then they decided to take
the law into their own hands and a man
died in the process I think even then
they have to be held accountable for
that unless there's some huge detail we
don't know about which is possible
another thing to think about you know
people are saying why did our burry
attack the guys with the loaded guns
rather than trying to run away well
first of all it seems like he did
originally try to run away second put
yourself in his shoes for a moment even
if you did commit a burglary right okay
even so
isn't that doesn't change this to guys
with guns are chasing you now they
stopped their car they get out guns in
hand they're telling you to stop come
with them or at least come to them they
aren't cops they're just random guys
with guns do you go with them do you
stop do you listen do you have some kind
of obligation to listen to them you
might well think look these guys are
gonna kill me
IIIi can't run because I can't outrun a
bullet my only choice is to fight is a
classic fight-or-flight scenario and not
everybody is a fighter in that situation
but some people are and I would say that
generally speaking the fighting is this
is a smarter choice this is the problem
with civilians doing this kinda stuff
now if those were cops then we could say
two things number one you have an
obligation to stop if they tell you to
stop that obligation may not be absolute
there could be situations where even
even in that you know where you don't
have to stop but most of the time you no
cop tells you stop you stop and you
listen number two if you stop for a cop
you can be reasonably certain they
aren't going to kill you again neither
of those apply when it's two random
dudes in a pickup with guns telling you
to stop you have no obligation to listen
to them to do what they say as far as
you know they plan to kill you and what
if you did commit a burglar does that
mean that you just have to give yourself
up to be killed say well they got me I
mean if you're gonna kill me go ahead I
wouldn't do that
in fact I would go so far as to say if
two random guys with guns pull up in a
pickup truck the absolute last thing you
should do is stop for them listen to
them go with them you should fight them
or run you never go with it with a
random guy with a gun when he tells you
to never well you got all these people
now defending the the shooters on the
basis that well you should have listened
to them what so now you're saying that
anyone who grabs a gun and points it at
you you're you have an OP it's not just
that it's the smart thing to listen but
you have an obligation to listen
no no now if they were cops I would say
the absolute last thing you should do is
try to fight the cops or flee them but
these were not cops and that really
really matters that's why we don't do
armed vigilantism in this country in a
civilized society especially when the
alleged supposed crime burglary doesn't
warrant that kind of reaction I mean I
could even like you know you know what
if if this was a situation where a guy
was was it was it was doing some
committing some heinous crime against
the person you caught him raping or
abusing a child or something and you
hear about these kind of cases and the
guy tries to run away and you chase him
down and kill him I would say in that
situation you know I I would be in favor
of you could plead like temporary
insanity you were blind with rage and I
I would be in favor of letting somebody
off on that basis not that we pass a law
saying it's legal to kill him on a few
but but but just in that situation even
I could see it because you're so
emotionally enraged by what you saw and
that you lose control of your faculties
and given the fact that the crime is so
heinous I'm going for your reaction will
fall on the person who committed the
heinous crime causing that reaction so I
could put for a burglary no sorry no you
don't chase down suspected burglars as a
civilian and kill them so that's where I
am on this right now open to new
information but based on what we know
that's where I am last thing okay I said
this was gonna be a lengthy discussion
of this on the racial angle obviously
there's obviously that that's gonna be a
part of this story and there are there
are people that are being very
irresponsible and it's trying to
basically stoke race rights I mean
LeBron James came out last night and
said something like you know every time
a black man leaves his house he's
two down just completely reckless
irresponsible dangerous rhetoric insane
absurd totally divorced from reality
right and so there's been that there's
been a lot of that I mean there are
there are irresponsible and bad people
out there who are interested in taking
advantage of these kinds of situations
to try to sow unrest we've seen that
before in the past and I'm very afraid
of that happening here but so you know
just because I'm saying it looks to me
right now this is unjust shooting and
these people should be held accountable
doesn't mean go out have a riot about it
and it also doesn't mean that they were
hunting down a black man out of some
racial motivated by racial hatred maybe
they were but we don't know that what I
will say is if it's if option number two
is correct that they did witness a crime
then I think that that doesn't
necessarily justify what they did but it
does pretty much remove the racial angle
because then they're reacting to what
they saw happen not to the skin color of
the person who did it
and in order to in order to prove a
racial angle there you would have to
prove that these guys in the past have
seen white people committing crimes and
didn't chase them down but only chase
down black people when they see black
people commit crimes and if that
evidence exists then presented but I
doubt that evidence does exist so if he
did commit a crime they think it takes
the racial angle out if he was an
innocent man just going for a jog and
they thought he fit the description of a
burglar then I think it's hard at that
point to avoid the racial component of
it and it would seem like they profiled
him and he died in the process and so
but you know that's so that's why
between option one and two it does make
a significant difference which one it is
but I'm not sure that either option
would justify the shooting okay now for
your daily cancellation and but before
we do that actually want to take a
moment to tell you about Daily wires
newest most exclusive membership tear
the all-access insider the all access
inside our membership tier is our
premier level of membership all access
members get the benefits of other
membership tiers including an ad-free
website experience access to our live
broadcast the show library access to the
shows mail bags and full three hours of
the Ben Shapiro so show along with
dedicated
tutorials for ben shapiro you get all of
that all access number also get other
amazing benefits including of course the
singular the irreplaceable left is tears
tumblr they also get to join live
exclusive online Q&A s they get to
participate in the all-access live shows
as well so head over to daily wire calms
i subscribe to join daily wires all
access club with a new membership or an
upgrade and get 10% off with coupon code
walsh
that's daily wire calm so i subscribe
see you there okay now for your daily
cancellation and i'm and will do this
quickly i'm canceling
every media outlet media person and
person in general who had any opinion
about or cared it all about or was was
upset about for any reason the fact that
adele lost weight so to back up here for
a second adele the singer obviously
apparently took a picture recently on
instagram and she was she was skinny she
had lost weight okay good for i mean i
think good for her who cares at the end
of the day really or even at the
beginning of the day or dunno what time
of day i who cares the weight or lack
thereof of celebrities is just not
important even a little bit but this
event of adele losing weight provoked a
lot of reaction from people and many
articles were written many articles many
entire there are people who sat down and
wrote whole articles about adele losing
weight here are some of the headlines
inside Adele's weight loss experts sound
off on her new look what expert experts
on what adele looks like adele
appearance experts is that a a major now
in some colleges i wouldnt be surprised
the frenzy over Adele's weight loss has
forced me to confront my own issue with
body image another headline let's not be
amazed that multi-millionaire Adele can
lose weight another one why the photo of
a new slimmer Adele makes women feel
like me feel uncomfortable another one
Adele's new birthday photo thanking
frontline workers sparks debate on body
image and then CNN says Adele lost
weight are we allowed to praise that
the controversy here is that by praising
Adele for losing weight
could we be implicitly fat shaming could
we be insinuating that it's it's it's
better to be skinny than fat
could we be suggesting that fat is not
preferred not ideal and the answer to
all those questions of course is yes we
are suggesting that as well we should
excess fat is bad it's unhealthy it can
kill you
it's better not to have it Adele is a
healthier person now than she was before
when she had the extra weight that's it
now it doesn't mean you're a bad person
if you're fat it doesn't mean you're
worth less it doesn't mean you have no
value it doesn't mean that you're a
better person when you lose weight it
just means that it's better to lose
weight it's better not to be fat than to
be fat because you'll be healthier and
you'll live longer and your internal
organs will fare better in the long run
and so will your skeletal structure and
everything else about you your body will
be very happy that you're not fat
anymore and that's all that's it it's
not complicated but this really is my
problem with the whole fat acceptance
thing it's not just that that fat
acceptance tells people to accept and
celebrate unhealthy things about
themselves that's a problem too don't
get me wrong
but even more than that it encourages
people to be self-obsessed to see
everything through the lens of their own
ego which is something we all do anyway
we don't need more help with that so a
celebrity loses weight and their first
thought is how does this affect me
Adele lost a famous singer in England
lost weight how does this affect me
that's what I want to know answer it
doesn't at all not everything is about
you you ridiculous narcissists you're
canceled all of you cancelled finally
since I've already gone wildly off track
and banned in my normal show format
let's keep the chaos going and throw out
the email segment for today and for this
because I want to do a special segment
about Mother's Day with Mother's Day
fast approaching I wanted to take a
moment and I feel like I don't do this
enough but I really wanted to give just
some practical advice that might be
helpful to you so is we talk a lot about
issues and ideas and everything and
oftentimes I feel like it's not
practical enough and people say to me
sometimes what are the practical
solutions meant when you're all about
complaining which is true it's my
favorite thing to do give me some
practical steps some practical things I
can do okay well here you go
so for any guys out there I'm gonna pass
along five suggestions for Mother's Day
gifts for your wife specifically and
these gifts might have might work for
your mom as well but I'm really focusing
on what you give to your wife because
even though we're in the middle of a
pandemic you are not off the hook all
right you definitely are not you've got
to do something and you have to make it
good too because your wife is under a
lot of stress so let's talk about these
here are my for Mother's Day gift ideas
number one this is a classic kind of a
cliche but there's a little bit of a
twist to it
so first suggestion is a mop now you're
thinking yeah mops a great gift but I
gave my wife a broom for Christmas isn't
this redundant well no first of all
because it's important to have the
complete set and your wife's can be
excited about that she's gonna call all
her friends and say I finally got it I
got the full cleaning set like I always
wanted but also here's the twist you're
gonna give her a little card and inside
the card you're gonna have suggestions
for areas of the house
that really need to be mopped than most
and what she'll love because the means
are paying attention is if you put the
date of the last time that area of the
house was mopped and so it puts a little
urgency on it but it also shows that you
are paying attention to the chore she
does in the house and the chore she knew
Lex she will like that
number two this one's pretty fun it gets
pretty creative but get her a pair of
pants that's intentionally three sizes
too small and on the inside of the
waistband right a little romantic note
that says you'll get their number three
now if you're looking for something
that's of maybe a bit more spiritual I
know there are a lot of you know devout
Christians who watch this show as I am
as well so here's a good one for you you
can get your wife you know those
pictures people like to have in their
homes now of like famous quotes and
things like that so you could do that
but this one it's gonna be a framed
picture of Ephesians 5:22 wives submit
yourselves to your husband's as you do
the lord of course famous quote
important thing though is don't include
the rest of that passionate passage that
talks about all the stuff a husband is
supposed to do because that's not really
the point is it this is about her it's
Mother's Day it's not about you for
finally maybe so far the ideas haven't
been quite sentimental enough and you're
looking for something that's very
personal to you very intimate even
something that shows how much you love
or something that shows you know just
how much you care and that you really
put some thought into it so here's an
idea what you want to do is is is think
about a piece of jewelry think about a
piece of jewelry that you bought for an
ex-girlfriend when you guys were dating
and then go and get that same jewelry
for your wife
explaining while you give it to her tell
her that this is the same jewelry that
you bought for an ex-girlfriend years
ago so the idea is it's kind of a
symbolic passing of the torch from the
girlfriend to the wife even if you've
been married for 10 years it's not too
late for the passing of the torch and
then your wife will appreciate it even
more if you kind of reminisce with her
and tell her a few stories about the
women you've dated and the fun things
you did wives always love to hear about
that stuff especially on special
occasions so those are my four Mother's
Day gift ideas I'm not going to be using
any of these ideas myself but only
because I don't
want to take the ideas from any of you
and I don't want to steal your thunder
so I'll be doing something else probably
something like along the lines of
flowers you know boring patronizing and
salting so don't do that take these
ideas and you will not regret it trust
me and we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you want to cut through
the madness of our politics and culture
and know what's really going on head on
over to the Michael Noel's show where we
can all bask in the simple joys of being
right see you there
[Music]